haben wir schnell auf die nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt der wird es nämlich
gehen um einen entwurf ein gesetzentwurf
der bundesregierung zum themenfeld
ökolandbau und öko kennzeichnungs
gesetzes geht in erster linie um eine
irgendwie umsetzung einer eu-verordnung
die entsprechend angepasst werden muss
geht also um die kennzeichnung von öko
lebensmitteln beispielsweise das geht
die zulassung von kontrollstellen zur
prüfung der öko qualität und alles
weitere werden wir jetzt in dieser
debatte hören die eröffnet werden wird
von hans-georg von der marwitz aus der
unionsfraktion er ist mitglied im
ausschuss für ernährung und
landwirtschaft
jetzt wird hier schnell noch die
rotation angemahnt weil natürlich die
fachpolitiker aus dem bereich arbeit und
soziales sie jetzt das plenum verlassen
und die abgeordneten die sich mit dem
themenfeld ernährung in der
landwirtschaft beschäftigen reinkommen
gehörig schnell auf den hinweis dass wir
das plenum zumindest im normal in
anführungszeichen fernsehprogramm gegen
zehn vorübergehend verlassen werden für
eine pressekonferenz eine weitere des
bundesgesundheitsministers aber in
unserem youtube kanal das ganze weiter
senden werden jetzt aber an georg von
der marwitz und auch die maske
abgenommen hat und deswegen ein bisschen
besser verständlich ist denn dies wird
wohl meine letzte rede hier im deutschen
bundestag sein zwölf jahre habe ich
meine fraktion als sprecher für den
ökologischen landbau gedient deshalb
freue ich mich sehr dass wir heute sogar
in der kernzeit dieses über dieses
wichtige thema sprechen
wir wollen eine deutliche verbesserung
für die branche auf den weg bringen
doch dazu gleich mehr der ökologische
landbau ist längst der nische entwachsen
in den vergangenen zehn jahren hat sich
die wahrnehmung aber auch der einfluss
des ökolandbaus enorm entwickelt
diskussionen über dieses thema waren zu
beginn meiner abgeordnetentätigkeit
vielfach von ideologie
und lagerdenken geprägt streitigkeiten
zwischen konventionell einerseits und
ökologisch andererseits wurden nicht
selten mit latente aggressivität
ausgetragen
die an das erledigt die debatte heute
gemeinsamkeit und der konstruktive
austausch überwiegen wenn es darum geht
die vorstellungen und wünsche der
verbraucher mit den
produktionsbedingungen in einklang zu
bringen
nachhaltige lebensführung bewusste
ernährung und ein so genannter grüner
lifestyle sind heute im mainstream
angekommen
ihm können und dürfen wir uns nicht
verschließen wachsende marktanteile
überzeugen deutlicher als der moralische
zeigefinger
wir befinden uns mitten in einem prozess
der nahezu alle gesellschaftlichen
bereiche berührt als land revolution
unternehmer müssen wir uns dabei
lernfähig und kompromissbereit zeigen
wenn wir auch zukünftig erfolgreich
produzieren und verarbeiten wollen die
welt des einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts
selbst gewissermaßen ein neues denken
voraus
werte wie nachhaltigkeit und
sozialverträglichkeit müssen wir mit
wirtschaftlichkeit zusammendenken ob im
agrarbereich bei der ernährungssicherung
oder auch in der forstwirtschaft
nachhaltigkeit und verantwortliches
denken in generationen sind heute in
zeiten des klimawandels wichtiger denn
je
auch technik und fortschritt leisten
einen wichtigen beitrag links hat die
digitalisierung in allen bereichen der
land- und forstwirtschaft einzug
gehalten und überbrückt die einstigen
gegensätze zwischen konventionell und
ökologische wirtschaftsweise als
sprecher für den ökolandbau musste ich
oft auch innerhalb meiner eigenen
fraktion für mehr offenheit werken
dabei halfen mir die praktischen
erfahrung aus meinem beruflichen alltag
seit 20 jahren wirtschaftlich meine
eltern nach ökologischen richtlinien die
mehrfache identifikation als landwirt
unternehmer und als parlamentarier hilft
bei der einordnung politische
entscheidung
das bild des politikers hat sich in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten deutlich
gewandelt
weg von praktiker hin zum
berufspolitiker
verzeihen sie mir ich sehe diese
entwicklung eher skeptisch der
landwirtschaftsausschuss bildet eine
besondere ausnahme die meisten nicht
immer frei von kritik
trotzdem bin ich der meinung dass die
positiven aspekte überwiegen wenn
politiker einen beruflichen bezug zu
ihrem fachbereich haben
daher war ich stets dankbar mit euch
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen den
dialog zu suchen und meinungen
auszutauschen
in den bereichen landwirtschaft
tiermedizin bayern-profi hat und
gastronomie hauswirtschaft und forst und
jagd unser ausschuss bildet die
landwirtschaft in ihrer ganzen vielfalt
ab doch nun zurück zum eigentlichen
öko-landbau gesetz mit dieser novelle
haben hier ganze arbeit geleistet
natürlich setzen wir in erster linie die
neue gegen öko basis verordnung um
gleichzeitig packen wir haben die
gelegenheit beim schopfe um unser
nationales biorecht weiterzuentwickeln
und bisherige unklarheiten zu beheben
gerade im parlamentarischen verfahren
konnten wir den ursprünglichen entwurf
noch einmal an entscheidenden stellen
verbessern und zwar im wesentlichen an
drei stellen zum ersten sichern gehen
dass plädierte zweistufige
kontrollsystem ab die zusammenarbeit
zwischen öffentlichen behörden und
privaten kontrollstellen ist ein
erfolgsmodell das wir gerne erhalten
wollen
mit dem vorliegenden gesetz stellen die
dieses modell erstmals auf eine wirklich
verlässliche und klare rechtsgrundlage
insbesondere sorgen wir für eine
eindeutige zuordnung und aufgaben im
kontrollen zertifizierungssystem wir
liegen test unter welchen bedingungen
die privaten kontrollstellen als
verlängerter arm der behörden agieren
dürfen welche aufgaben die länder ihnen
übertragen wollen bleibt ihnen weiterhin
frei gestellt diese klarheit ist wichtig
und entlastet alle seiten entlastung
aber vor allem effizienz versprechen wir
uns von einem zweiten einer zweiten
änderung mit der harmonisierung
überwachung der kontrollstellen
verhindern wir einen föderalen
flickenteppich bauen bürokratie ab und
sorgen für effiziente
verwaltungsstrukturen und drittens wir
wollen auch die außer haus verpflegung
stärken
der gestern veröffentlichte ernährungs
report zeigt dass viele menschen die
während der pandemie zu hause gekocht
haben auf dem bio geschmack gekommen
sind
diesen um 17% ich lobe 17 prozent
gestiegenen absatz wollen wir
aufrechterhalten indem wir küchen und
kantinen ermöglichen mit ihrem bio
anteil zu werden sobald sie wieder
öffnen können
mit der verordnungsermächtigung schaffen
wir die voraussetzung um die
zertifizierung von bio zutaten in der
außer-haus-verpflegung künftig flexibel
und praktikabel zu ermöglichen
wenn wir unser ziel von 20 prozent öko
landbau bis 2030 erreichen wollen dürfen
wir keine zeit verlieren mit dieser
novelle leisten dazu einen guten beitrag
die arbeit an diesem gesetz hat mir noch
einmal gezeigt wie gut wir auf der
fachebene zusammenarbeiten können an
dieser stelle auch noch einmal einen
besonderen dank an dicht macht uns einen
ganz herzlichen dank
und auch da einen mitarbeiter nach
diesem kurzen aber sehr intensiven
beratungen zum ende der legislatur
möchte ich jetzt einfach mal danke sagen
von ganzem herzen danke an meine
kollegen aus der fraktion und koalition
es waren gute starke zwölf jahre die
hier dabei sein durfte
trotz der klaren rollenverteilung
zwischen koalition und opposition im
ausschuss war es stets möglich
wertschätzend und fachlich miteinander
zu arbeiten
dafür danke ich auch der opposition
liebe kirsten tackmann die bafin
ostendorf übergangs busen und
stellvertretend einige zu nennen mit
euch habe ich gerne gestört
und auch diskutiert es war bereichernd
weil ihr aus dem fachlichen greifen
konnte und das überzeugt ebenfalls
danken möchte ich dem bundesministerium
für ernährung landwirtschaft und forsten
liebe von ministerin lieber
staatssekretäre sowie allen mitarbeitern
es war wunderbar mit ihnen
zusammenzuarbeiten
ich werde sie alle sehr vermissen
gleiches gilt für die mitarbeiter des
agrarausschusses in unseren abgeordneten
büros ohne ihre unterstützung und
vorbereitung wäre unsere arbeit nicht
möglich gewesen
danke alois gerig der gesamten
mannschaft die professionalität und der
hohe grad an organisationen mit dem der
bundestag arbeitet beruht wesentlich auf
dem einsatz vieler kräfte im hintergrund
die für ordnung und einen reibungslosen
betrieb sorgen
ihnen allen gilt mein besonderer dank
nicht zuletzt mitarbeitern des
fahrdienstes die saal bediensteten
partnerinnen und partner
sicherheitsdienste versorgungs
dienstleister dem reinigungspersonal
ihnen allen ein herzliches vergelt's
gott
das parlament ist die herzkammer unserer
demokratie die akzeptanz seine abläufe
und gepflogenheiten gibt für mich mit
der dankbarkeit für unsere freiheitliche
grundordnung einher
wenn mir einst wirklich bewusst geworden
ist in diesen zwölf jahren dann ist es
die würdigung unserer parlamentarischen
demokratie auf der grundlage unserer
verfassung
sie ist ein ergebnis des zusammenwirkens
von frauen und männern die deutschland
aus den verstrickungen seiner
unsäglichen vergangenheit lösen wollten
ihr werk hat eine stabile und wehrhafte
demokratie geschaffen
im zusammenspiel mit den föderalen
strukturen aufbauend auf ländern und
gemeinden was einem immerwährenden
prozess des interessenausgleichs mit
sich bringt die ständige suche nach
mehrheiten ist kein webfehler der
demokratie sondern der garant für
frieden und freiheit und das ab
der gefahr das verfassungsfeindliche
strömungen die oberhand gewinnen wenn
ich mich heute hier bei ihnen
verabschiedet dann tue ich dies in
dankbarkeit und erleichterung zugleich
hinter mir liegen zwölf besondere jahre
nicht immer ganz einfache und dennoch
unvergessliche ich danke für die
möglichkeit unserem land in diesem hohen
haus gedient zu haben
danke hans georg von der marwitz hat
hier seine letzte rede im deutschen
bundestag gehalten ein klein wenig
wehmut haben wir raus gehört aber auch
viel respekt vor der zusammenarbeit
nicht den abgeordneten anderer
fraktionen und software sprich zu ihr
bis ende oktober dauert möchte ich
gleichwohl den dank den sie allen
ausfuhren lagen auch im namen aller
fraktionen alle familien applaudiert ein
ziel dieser arbeit richten
wir wünschen ihnen für weitere aber die
deutschen bundestag und für das leben
und ihre tätigkeit danach von herzen
alles gute
dankesworte des bundestags präsidentin
an hans-georg von der marwitz wird zu
recht darauf hingewiesen hat dass man
sich hier möglicherweise doch noch das
eine und andere mal durch auch es
treffen kann
im deutschen bundestag den die wahl am
26 september ist unter umständen
natürlich jetzt war ich etwas abgelenkt
weil ich nämlich einen blick werfer auf
die bundespressekonferenz die sie in
unseren kleinen bild schon seit einer
geraumen zeit sehen wo um 10 uhr
beginnen soll
eine pressekonferenz mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister mit dem
präsidenten des robert koch instituts
und wenn ich jetzt das richtig in
erinnerung habe auch mit henriette reker
der oberbürgermeisterin von kölner wird
man also auch die kommunalen aspekte der
an die bekämpfung noch einmal erörtern
in dieser pressekonferenz sehr große
vorteil ist ja im moment dass die zahlen
rückläufig sind an neuinfektionen dass
auch alle anderen werte die im
zusammenhang mit der pandemie betrachtet
werden rückläufig sind die lage sich ein
klein wenig zu entspannen scheint und
die große frage jetzt natürlich ist wie
konsequent muss man und wie lange muss
man bei den massnahmen bleiben die im
moment noch gelten um diese entwicklung
auch weiter in dieser form zu halten ich
wollte noch ein kurzes wort verwenden
auf hans georg von der marwitz der ja
auch ehrenamtlicher präsident der
arbeitsgemeinschaft deutscher
waldbesitzerverbände ist eine wie gesagt
ehrenamtliche tätigkeit da wird es
sicherlich noch eine weile tätig bleiben
und wir werden das wollte ich auch noch
sagen vorhin das eine und andere mal
sicherlich noch hören dass hier die
letzte rede oder die mutmaßlich letzte
rede zumindest im parlament angekündigt
wird jutta krellmann die wir vorhin
gesehen haben in der debatte zur
betrieblichen mitbestimmung und die auch
heute morgen bei uns zu gast über im
interview war wird ebenfalls aus dem
parlament ausscheiden ist eine ganze
reihe von gesichtern werden in der
nächsten legislaturperiode wenn nicht
mehr da sein aber sie werden
möglicherweise alle nochmal wiederkommen
müssen auch wenn die zwei regulären
sitzungswoche neben in den kommenden
wochen vorüber sein werden denn alle
gehen davon aus dass sich das parlament
anfang september noch einmal
zusammenfinden muss um entscheidungen zu
treffen etwa zum fortbestand oder auch
zur aufhebung der epidemischen lage
nationaler tragweite wer sehe ich auf
meinem monitor dass der
bundesgesundheitsminister eingetrudelt
ist und mit ihm der präsident des robert
koch-instituts habt ihr nur ein sehr
kleines vorschaubild so dass wir die
kolleginnen und kollegen mit dem kameras
und fotokameras mir jetzt den blick
verdecken unter umständen auf henriette
reker
könig habe ich kann sie gerade hier
nicht hinzusehen vermute mal dass sie da
ist aber ich muss mich da auch ein klein
wenig jetzt dem schicksal überlassen und
vermutet dass in wenigen sekunden diese
pressekonferenz beginnen wird und dann
würde ich doch sagen doch kollegen das
leben mal groß und überlassen das feld
den kolleginnen und kollegen der
bundespressekonferenz ist der mündige
bürger wenn mehr mitbürger zu
biologischen produkten greifen und diese
auch bezahlen können dann erhöht sich
doch automatisch der anteil der
ökologischen landwirtschaft eine
staatliche zusatz subventionierung am
markt vorbei ist daher nicht nötig
diesen plan wirtschaftlichen ansatz
lehnen wir ab und begrüßen daher die
neue kennzeichnung regelung für den
außer haus verzehr
wir werden uns bei abstimmung aber
dennoch enthalten und das liegt vor
allem daran dass dieses prinzip ein
weiteres beispiel für die
alternativlosigkeit dieser regierung ist
der deutsche bundestag wiederbeleben
kann doch gar nicht anders als diesem
gesetz zuzustimmen
eine nichtannahme der eu richtlinie
würde zu einem
vertragsverletzungsverfahren führen und
hohe kosten für die steuerzahler
verursachen
wir brauchen echte europäische
zusammenarbeit und keinen bilder
garantie moloch namens eu wir fordern
raus aus diesem bürokratie monster
namens brüssel
raus aus kontrolle und ramos aus
fehlgeleiteter subvention ich danke
ihnen wünsche ihnen ein geistreiches
pfingstfest
jetzt eilig dass man die kollegin isabel
merkens in spd
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe frau
ministerin
der gesetzentwurf dient der anpassung
der eu land das im ökolandbau gesetzt
und das öko kennzeichen des setzte das
haben wir schon gehört im hinblick auf
die neufassung unionsrechtliche
verordnung die die neue bio basis
verordnung tritt am ersten januar 2022
in kraft sowohl für die bio branche als
auch für die zuständigen
kontrollbehörden und kontrollstellen
braucht es deshalb rechtssicherheit
daher ist es unabdingbar dass wir noch
diese legislaturperiode die anwendung
des öko landbau rechts sicherstellen
dass bio gut zeigen die umsatzzahlen im
jahr 2020 wurden fast 15 milliarden euro
umsatz in der biobranche erzielt das ist
eine umsatzsteigerung von 22 prozent zum
vorjahr somit zeigen viele menschen an
der ladenkasse dass sie mit bereit sind
mehr geld für gesunde und
umweltfreundliche bio lebensmittel zu
zahlen
in deutschland wurden im jahr 2020
insgesamt auf 10 2 prozent der bio der
fläche bio lebensmittel angebaut in
rheinland pfalz sind wir schon ein
bisschen weiter nicht nur bei diesem
punkt aber eben auch hier bei uns wird
bereits auf 11,7 prozent ökologisch
zertifiziert gewirtschaftet dass
nachhaltigkeit ziel der bundesregierung
sind 20 prozent öko landbau bis zum jahr
2030 um dieses ziel zu erreichen müssen
wir aktiv voran geben denn wenn wir auf
die zahlen schauen dafür bleiben keine
zehn jahre mehr
bei den verhandlungen zum bundeshaushalt
2021 haben wir als spd-fraktion deshalb
für eine erhöhung der öko forschung und
5 millionen euro sowie für die
möglichkeit zur verlängerung der
projektlaufzeiten von drei auf fünf
jahren haben wir uns stark gemacht und
dieser auch so verankert
der jetzt vorliegende regierungsentwurf
des bundeslandwirtschaftsministeriums
geht uns als regierungsfraktionen und
auch den bundesländern nicht weit genug
denn es gilt die rahmenbedingungen
für eine zukunftsfähige ökologische
lebensmittelwirtschaft zu verbessern
deshalb haben wir im parlamentarischen
verfahren auch an dieser stelle nochmal
herzlichen dank an hans-georg von der
marwitz nochmal kräftig beim ökolandbau
gesetz nachgebessert in drei
entscheidenden punkten erstens die
bundesanstalt für landwirtschaft und
ernährung wird zukünftig neben der
zulassung und dem entzug der
kontrollstellen auch für die
durchführung des jährlichen audits im
rahmen der überwachung der
kontrollstellen verantwortlich sein
das führt zu einer harmonisierung und
entbürokratisierung durch eine stärkere
koordinierung durch den bund zweitens
wir sorgen für eine klare definition und
zuweisungen der hoheitlichen und nicht
hoheitlichen aufgaben um das seit 27
jahren praktizierte und vor allem
bewährte zwei schriftliche
kontrollsystem zu sichern und auf eine
verlässliche und rechtliche basis zu
stellen
damit schaffen wir eine bessere
rechtsgrundlage und angemessene
finanzierung der kontrollstellen
drittens durch eine ermächtigung im
ökolandbau gesetz für eine
rechtsverordnung soll die verwendung von
bio zutaten in einrichtungen der
außer-haus-verpflegung gesteigert werden
denn derzeit liegt der bioanteil und das
ist wirklich erschreckend in der
außer-haus-verpflegung bei nur etwa ein
prozent
das ist ganz klar zu wenig die nachfrage
nach bio lebensmittel muss angeregt
werden um den ökologischen landbau hier
neue wachstumsimpulse zu geben
mit der verordnungsermächtigung soll
außerdem sichergestellt werden dass die
detaillierten einzelheiten im umgang
bioprodukten in der
außer-haus-verpflegung flexibel geregelt
und die ergebnisse des bahnprojekts mehr
bio mit zertifikat in der
außer-haus-verpflegung zeitnah umgesetzt
werden
mit dem angepassten gesetzentwurf senden
wir ein klares signal für die
entwicklung von bio in deutschland werde
spd bundestagsfraktion ist die
ökologische landwirtschaft ein wichtiges
element einer zukunftsfähigen und
nachhaltigen lebensmittelproduktion in
deutschland denn in der praxis zeigen
über 34.000 biobetriebe wie alternative
pflanzenschutzmaßnahmen eine vielfältige
fruchtfolge eine steigerung der
artenvielfalt und vorbeugend der
gewässerschutz funktionieren kann den
ökologischen landbau als vorbild zu
nehmen ist für eine zukunftsfähige
landwirtschaft unerlässlich dabei machen
sie war das mitglied im ausschuss für
ernährung und landwirtschaft und das
ganze für die spd-fraktion und wir
schauen auf die nächste rednerin carina
konrad wird das seien aus der fdp
fraktion wäre der bundestag weiter
diskutiert über öko landbau gesetze
eingeschliffene strukturen auch mal neu
zu denken und es setzt umdenkungsprozess
in der gesamten landwirtschaft in frage
und dass die landwirtschaft selbst schon
viel viel weiter ist als viele politiker
im zusammenwirken zwischen den beiden
produktionsformen das haben sie sehr
schön ausgeführten das unterstütze ich
ausdrücklich
wer die vorteile
zwischen landbaus allerdings
ausschließlich auf kosten der
konventionellen betriebe betreibt und
das tun leider parteien nach wie vor und
auch fraktionen hier in diesem hause
der schaden am ende des tages beiden und
wir freie demokraten wir tun das nicht
wenn wir stehen an der seite aller
landwirte unabhängig von ihrer
produktionsform egal ob bio oder
konventionell werde ich an recht und
gesetz hält werde ich den
herausforderungen der zukunft stellt und
wer die nachfrage auch immer mit blick
auf den kunden weiterentwickelt der
verdient wertschätzung und anerkennen
aber es geht eben auch die
herausforderungen ganz klar zu benennen
und wir reden in diesem haus sehr selten
über den ökolandbau und auch der öko
landbau hat herausforderungen denen er
sich stellen muss den ökolandbau gibt es
eben nicht zum nulltarif
frau merkel hat das eben sehr schön
aufgeführt auf der einen seite findet
eine hohe subventionierung eine
umstellung auf förderung statt die mit
der gießkanne auch stattfindet um ein
angebot zu schaffen und das angebot ist
sehr unterschiedlich wenn man sich mal
die zahlen anguckt sind wir bei
getreideprodukten gerade mal bei einem
marktanteil von drei prozent bei milch
von vier prozent bei schreiben heute
unter einem prozent zwar ständig sind
wir bereich von obst gemüse und eiern
und weil das so unterschiedlich ist und
weil man das auch einfach sehen muss und
das nicht gesehen wird versucht man
jetzt auf der anderen seite eine
nachfrage auf rezept zu verordnen
sie haben die öffentliche einrichtungen
angesprochen das hat nichts mit einer
gesunden marktentwicklung zu tun
das unterbindet den wettbewerb der ideen
und das führt auch zu importe von
fragwürdigen öko produkten aus dem
nicht-eu-ausland und das gilt es zu
vermeiden
und wir müssen auch die scheuklappen
es gibt negative effekte die größten
kostentreiber im ökolandbau sehen die
niedrigen erträge und der schmutzigste
fleck auf der weißen weste ist das nach
wie vor auch kupferprodukte eingesetzt
werden müssen um die krankheiten zu
vermeiden und die lösung beider probleme
die liegt nicht darin einen zu
stigmatisieren sondern die lücken in der
weiterentwicklung und vor allen dingen
in der züchtung und wer hier sich
verschließen auch vor den chancen die
neue züchtungsmethoden bieten
der hilft im ökolandbau nicht auf dauer
es schadet ihm und wir freie demokraten
ich stehe an der seite aller landwirte
und frau mackensen hat die erfolge in
rheinland-pfalz benannt in
rheinland-pfalz haben wir erkannt dass
im neuen züchtungsmethoden in der
anerkennung von biotechnologischen
verfahren auch eine chance für die
zukunft steckt bei antec ist ein
beispiel dafür wiegt die erfolge
elements medizin sind und die spd in
rheinland pfalz hat diesen punkt auf
ganz prominent besetzt und das sollte
die spd vielleicht im bunten sich
abschauen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
dr kirsten tackmann die linke ist die
nächste sie denn über ministerin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen in dieser
debatte geht es um den öko landbau dass
forschung zu hören und die umsetzung
neuer eu regelung lange schien es als
würde die bundesregierung koalition hier
sehr zögerlich und inhaltlich
minimalistisch vorgehen
und das obwohl ausdrücklich
verbesserungen und weiterentwicklungen
ermöglicht hat und obwohl die ziele zum
ausbau des ökolandbaus jahr auf allen
ebenen durchaus ambitioniert sind die
bundesregierung wird 20 prozent der eu
kommission sogar 25 prozent und einzelne
bundesländer sagen 40 prozent öko
landbau bis 20.30 voraus man kann ja
über diese ziele durchaus trefflich
streiten aber wenn man sie tanzt bei
meint müssen auch die rahmenbedingungen
dazu passen und die abfälle und
sonntagsreden reichen dann eben nicht
aus deshalb waren wir als linke schon
besorgt angesichts der massiven kritik
an der vorlage aus dem
bundesagrarministerium und
offensichtlich hat das ja auch die
berichterstattenden aus den
koalitionsfraktionen herausgefordert
jedenfalls zeigt der änderungsantrag
dass sich da einiges bewegt hat und sie
haben gebraucht letzter sekunde
zugegebenermaßen ihre fraktion überzeugt
wobei es vermutlich in der spd ein
bisserl einfacher war sondern union dass
sie ändert dass der änderungsantrag dass
der änderungsantrag allerdings in
letzter sekunde als tischvorlage im
ausschuss vorgelegt wurde wird dem thema
eigentlich nicht ist dem thema nicht
angemessen aber sei es drum
die änderungen gehen in die richtige
richtung und deshalb kann die linke dem
gesetzentwurf jetzt auch zustimmt dem
geänderten logischerweise zwei punkte
waren uns dabei besonders wichtig
erstens die absicherung des zweistufigen
kontrollsystems also der kombination
zwischen behördlicher überwachung und
privaten kontrollstellen das ist jetzt
geregelt das ist gut und zweitens ein
passenden rechtsrahmen für mehr bio in
der außer-haus-verpflegung
einschließlich kita und schulverpflegung
hier gefühl wird zumindest die tür sehr
weit aufgemacht das ist aus sicht der
linken auch deshalb wichtig weil es eben
nicht reicht den ökologischen anbau zu
fördern
wer land wirtschaftlich produziert
braucht verarbeitungs und
vermarktungsstrukturen das gilt erst
recht im weg über die vielen fehlen
müssen ökoprodukte bioprodukte am ende
durch konventionell vermarktet werden
das dann das hilft dann zwar der umwelt
trotzdem aber eben nicht im agrarbetrieb
denn am ende bekommen die natürlich nur
den konventionellen erzeugerpreis und
das führt immer wieder dazu dass öko
betriebe aufgeben oder aufgeben müssen
deshalb ist es auch aus sozialen gründen
wichtig bio in der
außer-haus-verpflegung zu erleichtern
wobei es natürlich uns als trinken auch
richtig wichtig bleibt das dann außer
haus verpflegung auch bezahlbar bleibt
ein besserer zugang zur außer haus
verpflegung vor ort unterstützt übrigens
auch die regionale verarbeitung
vermarktung bei der koproduktion der
lange wege schaden oder shuttle schaden
auch der ökobilanz ökolandbau und das
können wir nun wirklich alle nicht
wollen vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit und das markierte
tackmann aus der linksfraktion
sprecherin für agrarpolitik in einer
debatte in der es um öko landbau gesetze
geht und da spricht nun harald ebner
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen sprecher
für waldpolitik sprecher für gentechnik
und bio ökonomie politik
sachen gibt's
herr präsident werde kolleginnen und
kollegen frau ministerin dass künast öko
siegel wird dieses jahr 20 jahre alt
allerdings erst im herbst
und warum dann frau klöckner einen im
juni bereits einen festakt zu machen
muss das wird ihr geheimnis bleiben aber
das macht sicher mehr spaß als sich mit
masken gate und anderen dingen zu
beschäftigen
zurück zum öko-landbau die
bundesregierung hat sich doch
tatsächlich dass unzählige ziel gesteckt
bis 20 30 20 prozent ökologischen
landbau zu erreichen wahnsinn dieses
ziel hat tatsächlich schon renate künast
im jahr 2001 ausgerufen und in sage und
schreibe 16 jahren unions geführte
agrarministerium sind sie noch nicht mal
in die nähe dieses ziels gekommen das
ist doch wirklich eine armselige bilanz
ich höre an dieser stelle schon an
dieser stelle schon die öko landbau
verhinderungs ministerin die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher die
sich so gern als bühne bullerbü
romantiker verhöhnt würden zwar von öko
reden ist aber am ende nicht kaufen das
gegenteil ist der fall wir haben doch
heute schon gehört bei der außer haus
verpflegung bereich ist der bereich wo
die menschen in der regel am wenigsten
wählen können am arbeitsplatz bei festen
und sonstwo letztes jahr fiel das alles
aus und die menschen haben gewählt um
unglaubliche 22 prozent ist der umsatz
an bio lebensmittel gestiegen 2020
wurden 50 prozent mehr bio fleisch und
damit auch mehr tirol eingekauft also
hören sie doch endlich auf ministerin
mit der dauernden verunglimpfung der
menschen in diesem land und am möglichen
sie ihnen endlich eine wirkliche wahl
gäbe es nicht gäbe es nicht einzelne
engagierte abgeordneten abgeordnete auch
in reihen der koalition ausdrücklichen
dank an den kollegen
von der marwitz auch dank für die gute
zusammenarbeit und an die kollegin
mackensen wirklich bis dienstagnacht
gegen die blockadehaltung des bmw
gerungen haben gebe es die nicht der
vorliegende gesetzentwurf wäre eine
katastrophe für die biobranche und erst
recht für die gesamte
außer-haus-verpflegung geworden sie
hätten ein bürokratiemonster und
ökolandbau schikanierung gesetz
geschaffen frau ministerin
so ist wenigstens das schlimmste
verhindert worden bei der umsetzung der
eu öko basis verordnung was wir aber
wirklich brauchen was sie wirklich
brauchen ist der wirkliche wille zu mehr
öko landbau statt ihn schlecht zu reden
haben es gerade von der kollegin konrad
gehört da läuft doch die graben freese
zwischen konventionellen und
ökologischen landbau starken schlecht zu
reden und so und schlecht zu verwalten
wie die frau ministerin brauchen wir
brauchen wir mehr ökolandbau klare ziele
engagierte ziele ich komme zum schluss
herr präsident die koalition hat sich 20
prozent zum ziel gesetzt die eu 25 in
baden württemberg wurden 30 bis 40
prozent öko landbau als ziel im
koalitionsvertrag festgeschrieben und
dazu brauchen wir maßnahmen dass wir
mehr klimaschutz mehr tirol tirol und
keine gentechnik in der ökologischen
landwirtschaft haben vielen herzlichen
dank herr alt war der vorletzte redner
die in einer debatte in der es um öko
landbau gesetze geht letzter redner wird
rainer spiering sein der complus
spd-fraktion und ist sprecher für
ernährung und landwirtschaft und dann
wird entsprechend abgestimmt über dieses
gesetz
herr präsident frau ministerin
kolleginnen und kollegen gesunde und
hochwertige lebensmittel zu erzeugen
dabei die natur zu schonen
in geschlossener stoffkreisläufe zu
arbeiten und nicht nur auf den
kurzfristigen ökonomischen gewinn zu
schauen
das sind die ziele der ökologische
landwirtschaft und einer nachhaltigen
landwirtschaft das genau wird auch die
spd fraktionen und kirsten tackmann um
das zu erwidern uns ging das in der tat
wirklich sehr einfach weil wir uns
vertrauensvoll auf dieser welt verlassen
haben sie hat das exzellent gemacht und
dafür liebe dieser welt herzlichen dank
für deine arbeit unter anleihen wird ich
möchte aber auch die gelegenheit nutzen
lieber hand gehen
das war eine tolle spannende jahren mit
dir gerade für dich an vielen stellen
dich einfach ganz ganz lieben herzlichen
dank für deinen einsatz und vor allen
dingen dass du etwas was in der union
eigentlich sehr schwierig ist nämlich
diese form der landbewirtschaftung
hochzuhalten hingekriegt hast dafür ganz
herzlichen dank und dafür können die das
ganze haus es ist nun gelungen die
verwaltungsabläufe bei den öko
kontrollen deutlich zu straffen und
vereinfachen
dabei soll es aber nicht bleiben
entscheidend für die entwicklung des
ökolandbaus ist die förderung die zweite
säule der gemeinsamen agrarpolitik ich
hab das gestern hier schon gesagt wir
fahren auch sechs von sechs auf 15
prozent hoch ich habe auch gestern schon
erwähnt das ist ein extrem schwieriger
weg war
aber je mehr ich darüber nachdenke desto
mehr ist mir eigentlich auch klar
geworden dass es am ende nicht reichen
wird
der geldbedarf einer sicht
transformieren de landwirtschaft ist
höher und ich finde dann muss man sehr
intensiv darüber nachdenken wie man
diesen geldbedarf decken kann und ich
finde da ist eigentlich der ökolandbau
ein seltenes beispiel und wir sollten
nicht mehr denken
vom vater vor sondern genau den
umgekehrten weg und der umgekehrte weg
heißt dass der staat als nachfrager
auftritt wie wäre es denn wenn wir die
öffentliche speisung oder schuld hat
jemand intensiv darum gekümmert dass die
kleinsten der kleinen versorgt werden
ist das im moment gewährleistet nein das
ist es nicht wir haben gerade in der
ernährung riesen unterschiede
und wie wäre es denn wenn wir als staat
krippe kita schule universität
krankenhäuser und die
altenpflegeeinrichtung richtig mit geld
versorgen und richtig mit geld heißt
milliardenbeiträge um dann eine
nachfrage zu konstituieren dies anbieter
sowohl ökologischen also konventionellen
möglich macht nach dieser nachfrage
anzubieten dass wir wirklich dann so
markt herstellen und wirklich in die
landwirtschaft in die regionale
landwirtschaft wirklich richtige
milliarden sowie hinein spülen um zwei
sachen zu erledigen einmal der regionale
landwirtschaft bei der versorgung die
möglichkeit zu geben das angebot zu
machen und endlich dafür zu sorgen dass
die kleinsten eher klein und die die
sich nicht helfen können endlich
gemeinsam und ordentlich versorgt werden
das wäre mein wunsch stellt sich in das
haben schließlich die auswahl und wir
kommen zur abstimmung über den von der
bundesregierung eingebrachten
gesetzentwurf zur änderung des öko
landbau gesetzes und des öko kennzeichen
gesetzes der ausschuss für ernährung und
landwirtschaft in velen zu einer
beschlussempfehlung auf der drucksache
29 8 56
ein gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung
auf der drucksache 28 4 0 4 in der
ausschuss fassung anzunehmen ich bitte
diejenigen die den gesetzentwurf in der
ausschuss fassung zu stehen wurden um
das anzeigen ist die koalition die linke
bündnis 90/die grünen wer stimmt dagegen
enthält sich
fd fdp in zweiter beratung ist der
gesetzentwurf damit angenommen
die beratung ist deshalb sich pd die dem
gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben dahin gesehen ja stimmt dagegen
dann gebe er enthält sich das ist das
was man mit breiter mehrheit nicht nur
die koalitionsfraktionen diesen
gesetzentwurf zugestimmt sondern auch
die grünen und die linken bei enthaltung
aus den reihen der fdp und der afd